There's more to know.
>> Laura: WELCOME BACK TO OUR
NEW AND RECURRING SEGMENT, THE
EXPERTS.
REMEMBER THOSE PROPHECIES OF
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S TWEETS THAT
HIS NUCLEAR BUTTON WAS BIGGER
THAN ROCKET MAN?
>> WE ALL LIVE IN A WORLD THAT
COULD BE ENDED IN TERMS OF A
HABITABLE PLANET BECAUSE OF THIS
TOLD HIM HOW THIS IS READING TO
THE REST OF THE WORLD.
>> HIS MENTAL INSTABILITY HAS
INTERSECTED WITH THE MOST
DANGEROUS ISSUE THAT HAS FACED
IS AS A PLANET.
>> Laura: CAN WE RETIRE THE 3D
CHESS VERBIAGE?
I'M TIRED OF THAT.
MAYBE THOSE EXPERTS CAN EXPLAIN
THIS.
GORDON CHANG.
WITH ME IN WASHINGTON, MICHAEL
TRUMP IS A DISASTER ON FOREIGN
POLICY.
SUDDENLY KIM JONG UN'S PEOPLE
TALKING TO SOUTH KOREA.
>> THE NORTH AND THE SOUTH ARE
TALKING.
DIPLOMACY IS THE ONLY WAY WE'RE
GOING TO SOLVE THIS THREAT IN
NORTH KOREA.
I THINK PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
COMMENTS TO DATE HAVE
EXACERBATED THE PROBLEM AND WHAT
WE ARE SEEING OUT OF KIM JONG UN
REACHING OUT TO THE SOUTH IS
TRYING TO POKE AND PROD FOR
WEAKNESS IN THE ALLIANCE OF
SOUTH KOREA AND THE
UNITED STATES.
HE SEEMS THE ERRANT TWEETS.
>> Laura: HE'S MEETING WITH
THE SOUTH BECAUSE OF THE TWEETS?
THAT COULD BE REVERSE PSYCHOLOGY
I'M MORE SCARED OF HIS TWEETS.
>> Laura: LET'S GO TO GORDON
CHANG REAL QUICKLY.
>> HE UNDERSTANDS THAT SANCTIONS
ARE HURTING HIS REGIME.
U.N. SANCTIONS PUT IN PLACE
U.S. SANCTIONS.
WE SEE THIS.
OF KIM JONG UN IN HIS NEW YEAR'S
HIS GOVERNMENT.
THERE IS ANECDOTAL EVIDENCE OF
SO MANY INSTANCES OF PEOPLE NOT
GETTING MONEY.
THIS IS A REAL INDICATION THAT
THE UNDERLYING TRUMP POLICY OF
CUTTING OFF MONEY TO THE
NORTH KOREAN REGIME IS STARTING
TO WORK.
THAT'S ONE OF THE REASONS WHY
KIM JONG UN WANTS TO TALK TO THE
PAY THEM CASH.
>> Laura: CLOSING THOUGHTS,
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE
UNITED STATES.
WHAT DOES THE TRUMP